[Music]
hey everybody it's sunday yeah hopefully
everybody's doing okay out there i
forgot that you were chewing gum like
yeah so try not to like get too close to
the microphone yeah
that's like kind of gross literally
working in a garden man i had to pull up
a whole bunch of damn sweet potatoes
made a bunch of them but not as many as
i thought
well messed up on the instructions that
yeah it's a long story
it's a long story next yield will be
better 90 days yeah big big sweet taste
big potatoes and then i'm taking all the
greens off the top of them
and they taste just like spinach i'm
going to turn them into sog sog paneer
versa it's salt with not sogg paneer but
sog which is like a yeah because we
don't have any paneer do you have
anything here
oh saga is like fortunately
indian spinach stew kinda
nice delicious yeah i mean i especially
didn't want it but yeah i especially
like it with paneer in it but yeah we
don't have anything i got some pork
tenderloin
yeah econobotson said i remember this
movie it's like predator in a way yeah
this movie is kind of like i had seen it
like a long time ago and i remember
really liking it
and then i'm kind of like uh
i was thinking well i thought tom would
really like it yeah i feel asleep and
then so i put it on and literally like
two minutes after it started he fell
asleep so he had to watch it by himself
today yeah so he knows that because i
was like yeah it's fun right yeah it's
like it's kind of like a trashy
b movie version
of predator 2 and blade run predator 2
and blade runner power
yeah well and matter of fact it's
interesting that you mentioned first
power because the guy that wrote the
screenplay for this movie
uh the screenplay was originally because
the name split second i was like that
has absolutely nothing to do with
anything like in the movie that and that
wasn't the original title the original
title was either pentagram or pentacle
and he wrote it back in the late 80s
and it kind of like made the rounds and
then finally like this producer came up
and said oh this seems like a good movie
but by the time that a producer had
gotten their
hands on it um they're like okay well
this is way too much like the first
power which had come out in 1990
um because originally this was supposed
to be set in la and there was like a
serial killer that was doing like
pentagrams that was killing so many
people like so they had to like change
it to something else
uh because it was absolutely too similar
to that but he had like i said he had
written it before that movie give this
the run down though
let me
let me cut to the chase of what we're
dealing with
this movie
it's a shitty movie but it's [ __ ]
enjoyable all right that's what i mean
yeah what they did
is they are kind of homaging every
arnold schwarzenegger
[ __ ] action adventure flick
and every stallone action they're kind
of homage and blade runner they're
they're they're homaging all these
[ __ ] classic films way too early
before you're supposed to homage them
it's kind of like
blade runner but low budget
it's predator 2
all right you got
rutger howard all right 47 year old
rucker howard they're trying to hide the
fact that tower that's not how yeah
what's his name again power howard
that's right
er no you said howard no with the d is
there anything i didn't say d on it yeah
rucker howard
and uh it he's slightly overweight in
this but he still looks pretty good
you got that
what's her name the chick from [ __ ]
kim kim control okay but just like uh
from mannequin and yeah well she still
had she still has the hair that she had
in the star trek movie yeah it was like
something from the star trek movie
because
she had this one star trek six or
whatever the [ __ ] she's probably
about 35 37 in it but she's
still attractive she's got this
hot
goth bob
with it's shaved a little bit on the
sides you know they keep showing that
off because that was very futuristic in
the 90s you also get to see your boobies
yeah she does yeah well there's a lot of
[ __ ] tits and ass
this is the british movie okay this is
the british it's a british american
co-production right but the british are
understanding it you know they're
rolling with it like yeah it's okay and
they don't have an american leading man
they got a damn is he dutch i think he's
dutch
so there he's basically playing a cross
between
roy batty
and
and and and uh deckard from blade runner
with every hard-boiled cop stereotype
over-the-top [ __ ] stereotypes on
everything
the tone is almost like
it's ridiculous okay but it's supposed
to be ridiculous this is like the tone
is arnold schwarzenegger uh uh well i'll
probably be more specifically the tone
is total recall
okay
um the visual style is goth industrial
from the 90s it looks like a damn front
242 video everybody in it whether what
they're dressed and everything kind of
like a pseudo-futuristic what 1992
thought would would futuristic would be
yeah because it's it was made in 1992
but it's supposed to be set in 2008.
yeah so what you end up with is two
front two four two and like goth
industrial that's what it looks like
everything's kind of paramilitary
looking
gray and black leather
uh then there's all these
tropes and stereotypes from earlier
movies like you got
the cop all right now rucker howard not
only is he doing not only is rucker
howard doing
uh uh um
uh uh deckard
not only uh who else that
was deckard and what else they say was
uh he's also a little bit of like uh
uh
the the dude from lethal weapon okay
that you know the character from league
of legends what was that character's
name crazy cop who was like on the edge
of it he's he's doing that
he's cop who doesn't play by the rule
copter doesn't play by the rules big
time his sidekick is basically
uh the sidekick from beverly hills cop
the uh what was his name like uh judge
reinhold's character yeah it was just
reinhold's character's name and beverly
hills um
um
the goofy
goofy freaking nerdy cop all right a
british cop in this case is br
not taggart oh [ __ ]
billy
billy was the uh what was the cops name
right damn billy you know he's like that
and man in the final engagement in the
final [ __ ] showdown with the monster
the sidekick is
in arnold schwarzenegger's terminator
one costume when he was dressed like a
punk rocker with a with a
black leather jacket he's just missing
the gargoyle glasses
but the boots and everything it's just
there's a lot of homages to [ __ ] in it
you understand it if you know
action movies
it's
it's it's
it's over the top it's ridiculous
but it stays within
the boundaries of it of an american
80s era action flick it doesn't go
outside of it too much to where it
becomes a parody it's not a parody
it's more like just an homage
to it
it was you would probably see it as a
parody today but i don't think they were
parodying anything back then no i just
had to stand up on 11 a little bit
yeah they just they it's over the top
but it's super it's super fun it's fun
yeah this is good it is very very
entertaining this movie is very energy
yeah the tone the tone is imagine if
predator
2 is happening in a front 242 video kind
of like blade runner
and the tone
is not serious like blade runner was the
tone is more like
like uh
again total recall kind of like that
that's the tone yeah i mean some of the
edge of reality some of the best [ __ ]
about oh and by the way it's also a
monster movie yeah
too yeah you're running out of some kind
of monster it's a rat
dna
so they're not real clear on that well
because
well because the thing that happened
like i said this movie um had a very
very troubled production history
initially it was supposed to be
more like the first power like like i
said the guy that originally wrote it um
you know who is the same guy that um
wrote later wrote like fast and the
furious and hollow man the one with uh
kevin bacon but so he wrote the script
originally and it was supposed to be
like about uh
like an occult serial kill it's supposed
to be like a buddy cop flick yeah but
with an occult tim it was like an occult
tinge serial killer like a satanist
serial killer so like i said eventually
what would become the first power so
it's kind of like that but then after it
got changed he was kind of like okay
well i'm going to make it more like
dystopian so he
made it like forward to like 2008 was
set in london now and it's like uh you
know futuristic where there's like
global warming and like the london parts
of london are flooded so like i said you
still have a dystopian thing going on
and it still has the occult element but
now it's almost but now it's like
supernatural because the serial killer
you find out later on is actually like
a demon
or it's well it's not real clear but
like i said i mean it was called black
tied at that point
which actually is kind of like a cooler
title even though it doesn't have a huge
amount to do with the movie either
although that does at least reference
like the flooding and stuff but
yeah so the monster
it looks like it looks like venom i mean
pretty much pretty much it looks like
the symbiote yeah
and and the xenomorph kind of but more
like venom
yeah it's a demon of some sort but it's
also like a mutant if it if it takes a
bite from you from you it steals your
dna
now how does that help it it does it's
not really clear evidently it learns
from you
i guess yeah well the thing about it too
is that uh you know rucker howard's
character his name is harley stone by
the way yeah um
he was wounded by the creature because
the whole thing is that the creature
killed his partner like three was it
three years previously something like
that and he is had didn't really get
over it all that well so now he's just
kind of like a bundle of nerves and he's
all like paranoid paranoid and stuff
and he so he got wounded and so now he
has a little bit of a psychic link
with the monster so he like happens but
he doesn't seem
all that aware of it like it's not
there's a lot of ideas in this but
they're not really developed but i don't
but you know what i don't even care
because this movie is just like super
super fun it's super gory yeah there's
boobies it's funny like the um it starts
with that too this starts yeah and i got
the industrial underground club and
there's a real hot famous uh british
stripper that i looked it up her name
was shaw something
tina shaw i think her name is you can't
really see her face though she's in a in
a bondage outfit but
they they highlight her shaking the
boobies around yeah yeah and her ass and
[ __ ] she she's kind of like
90s big fine that was like big five for
90s they didn't get much bigger than
that and then she'd be considered fat
but today she'd be just like
not even regular just kind of regular
move up because 80s uh girls were
usually like
sticks
the ones that they were presenting as
being real hot super skinny no booty and
big fake titties on them you know the
size of beach balls that would be like
that went on for a little while but that
that passed too but it was just yeah she
looked good
um everybody looked good kim looked
great she's 37 in it i checked
everybody's age she was 37 in it and uh
still uh very attractive good shape real
good shape um
pretty haircut that was a cool haircut
for for 92. that that was like a goth
industrial type haircut i'm just like
it's the beginning of a [ __ ] undercut
i'm just so used to
seeing her with different hair yeah
bob it's a black yellow fetish so it's
like i always it's every time i see her
in that with that haircut because i know
she got it for the star trek thing yeah
because this was made around the same
time um it always seems like a wig but i
don't think it is no it looks very
wiggish no and there's an undercut that
keeps showing you the fact that it's
shaved underneath there which he had two
that was that was like oh man that's
edgy that's really edgy she shaved her
head girls don't shave their heads
that's like
commonplace now but in 92 that was some
heavy heavy [ __ ] i shaved half my head
in the night in the mid 19 mid to late
1980s
[Laughter]
so the fashion in it is good it's got
good costumes especially for for that
time the sets where they were just
making [ __ ] up as they were going along
they're kind of cool and i mean this is
pretty low budget low budgets low budget
uh cool little vehicles they just take
down
jeeps and put roll bars on them they had
hovercrafts going around through the
streets because there was always like a
couple feet of water or a foot of water
everywhere so they had hovercrafts
little cheap ones um the cops did and uh
fake guns
those were [ __ ] air guns or
his main gun is a is a is a
is a uh
he they have they're giving like
futuristic names for him you know which
is that's kind of cool but there it was
a paintball gun based on a cold python
they put a damn forearm underneath it
like a stock and i guess what's supposed
to be against a red dot
he calls it an automatic but it's
obviously a revolver there's just all
kinds of [ __ ] up [ __ ] that's wrong in
it but it's just a fun game like i said
it's supposed to be the future like
it shoots explosive [ __ ] rounds kind
of like on a blade runner you know
pretty neat
um
they do everything they can to keep uh a
rucker in a damn jacket
because they don't want you to see
his waistline has expanded quite a bit
since the roy batty era but the thing
about that though it doesn't matter
though well one it doesn't matter and
two it's in line with his character
because
he's in the movie yeah yeah in the movie
it's like yeah his partner got killed uh
three years ago and he was there and he
couldn't prevent it
and now this serial killer what they
initially think is a serial killer but
who's actually a monster uh is back
again so he's getting like stressed out
about it
and so he's not
he's not okay you know what i mean so
it's fine that i mean he the apartment
that he lives at like the loft is like a
total [ __ ] he's basically like the
crazy cop from from um from lethal
weapon he's like that mixed with roy
batty i mean they said that he used to
be a drunk but he quit so now he's just
like now he just like mainlines coffee
and just has bags and bags of chocolate
yeah and he's got a [ __ ] up apartment
with harley davidsons and motorcycles
you know it's crazy it's crazy
everywhere the okay so living
every stereotype
and everything that [ __ ] rucker
howard did they got that yeah the pigeon
on you like in blade runner yeah they're
even like the whoo and all that kind of
[ __ ] him staring into the camera they
was doing stuff right from blade runner
just they know you saw these movies so
they
they're [ __ ] with you yeah you know
and then you know that then his sidekick
is dressed up as the terminator you know
they don't say it but you just look at
you know that's a terminator outfit this
is funny you know can i say like my
favorite part of this movie well i'm
gonna get back to what i was gonna say
in a second but my favorite part of this
movie is the interaction between
uh
between rutger hauer and the partner
yeah the partner's name the nerdy guy is
dick durkin that's
his character's name yeah so it's dick
durkin and he like makes fun of like his
uh his name and stuff but yeah he's like
a guy he's from oxford and he's like
studied psychiatry he's like studied
serial killers and stuff so he's kind of
one of those so he's like very so like
their interactions and their um you know
conversations with each other are like
super funny but what i was gonna say was
that despite this movie being like
surprisingly gory there's like a really
because the serial killer slash monster
he kills people by tearing their hearts
out and like so a lot of times they'll
show like the you know the aftermath and
they'll be like a person with their rib
cage sticking their [ __ ] blood
everywhere and yet with all of that in
there the grossest thing in this movie
was that at one point
when
kim cattrall is staying at uh
ruckerhauer's shitty loft apartment
he
took a bunch of like chocolate bonbon
things and stuck them all over the
refrigerator door like in a heart shape
and she took one off and ate it
and i was like
[ __ ] do you know what how many germs
are on the front of that refrigerator
this place looks like hasn't been
cleaned in like 100 years and she's just
like it's like oh how cute it like takes
it off horse and i was like
that's so gross now somebody says this
sounds like a blade runner rip off oh no
that doesn't even scratch the surface
it's right i mean it's ripping off
everything yeah it's in everything it's
ripping off every [ __ ] day okay and
it it knows that it's ripping it off and
it knows that you know that it's ripping
it off yeah and it's all right it's all
right
the tone is [ __ ]
crazy all right the tone is basically
uh you know
i just keep i just keep coming back to
um total recall i mean i laughed out
loud so many times watching this partly
ridiculous you know i heard him laugh
because i i heard him way down the hall
like i heard him laugh and i thought
yeah i did too like when i was watching
it it'll just it's [ __ ] hilarious
it's hilarious
and honestly it's like i think some
reviews of it said that it was
unintentionally hilarious i think i
think it was intentional i think it was
intentional because some of the some of
the stuff are homages and shout outs and
yeah and easter eggs and stuff you're
supposed to know what they're doing i
mean they're [ __ ] with you it's
obviously supposed to be funny it's
supposed to be kind of funny
and you know what i mean i mean
obviously well it's supposed to be
exciting and it's supposed to be
entertaining which is which it does that
yeah it's supposed to give you a bunch
of cool [ __ ] to trip out on you know to
look at and in 92 you would have gone
yeah yeah oh look at that [ __ ] you know
it's like like kind of like robocop some
of those
so the the color palette is kind of like
robocop when he like when they go into
the police station yeah stuff like that
just the way it is it's they knew what
they were doing they knew what they were
doing they knew that they had limited
budget so they better have a bunch of
entertaining [ __ ] in it which they did
and rucker howard acts he knocks it out
of the park
there's also about scenery oh yeah and
there's also a lot of really great uh
british character actors in this too uh
pete postelthwaite is in this
um ian durie is in this yeah has it like
and recognizable people in it yeah alan
armstrong he's [ __ ] great he's like
the head of the he's like the his
superior you know what i mean and he
just like takes it he just like swears
his head off what the [ __ ] is going on
it's like it's so [ __ ] great
it's great it's all practical effects
and they do stuff they show you stuff
there's gore in it
yeah there's a heart with a bite taken
out of it yeah the only thing that's
wrong with it really is the quality of
the way it was filmed and some of the
some of the scenes the lighting it was
kind of uneven it needs a remaster maybe
a uh uh and and it's
it looks a little hazy in certain scenes
yeah it's kind of hazy like they shot it
with a soft filter to hide something uh
probably you know bad quality [ __ ]
probably
yeah i mean this movie only cost seven
million dollars and it was shot in what
five days
i think it was a seven days no um
no i think three weeks three weeks i
think it was shot in three weeks but the
thing about it that's it the thing about
it though is that the original director
like i said they had a lot of they had
to make a lot of changes to the script
because you know they're like well we
don't really like
you know the first iteration of the
script because it's too much like the
first power so when they started adding
like this other dystopian stuff and then
like the original director who i said
was tony malem who was actually the same
guy that wrote that slasher movie the
burning
um
he made most of the movie and then like
he had i don't know if he had a nervous
breakdown but because of the stress he
was just like [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm out so
they actually had to get another
director to come in and finish it and
that was ian sharp who is actually the
guy that directed the action scenes in
goldeneye he didn't direct the whole
movie but just the action scenes so the
part at the end where he's like fighting
the monster and like pulls his heart out
and stuff um that was ian sharp
directing that and that was like a
little bit chaotic
but
but like i said i think the only flaw
and i don't even care about it because
like i said this movie is hilarious and
fun and gory and it's just a good time
you know what i mean it kind of reminds
me a bit of that movie haven't seen it
in a long time i got to see it again
it's one with brad dorf the one about
they were fighting a damn monster
wasn't it like a robot
and i think he's the only famous
permanent person i think brad dorff is
the only famous person in it he
basically plays kind of like a mad
scientist
remember that one uh
not death machine isn't it i think it is
death machine i think it's death machine
was he a death machine i think he was i
haven't seen that in a long time
you know what though uh death machine
had the same cinematographer i think as
this okay yeah it reminded me of death
machine because death machine so maybe
maybe that's why
uh death machine was real low budget
but it was fun to watch and they showed
you a lot of cool [ __ ] and it was all
practical yeah it was death machine
i can't believe i pulled that out yeah
and it was brad doroth in it and he was
just chewing up the [ __ ] scenery i
got to see i love brad i haven't seen it
he's played a long time
and uh he's just one of those guys that
every time he's in a movie it just makes
it better
this one uh from just based on memory
this one is a little more uh like longer
and there's more to it than death
machine i think death machine was kind
of short and real bizarre
that's just yeah i haven't seen it in a
long time so i got to see that one but i
did remember that this was the same
cinematography as death machines so
that's why they look away and debt
machine was low budget but high in
delivery it gave you something to look
at if you're gonna be low budget you
better be [ __ ] entertaining and i
remember being entertained from death
machine i gotta see it again and this
movie is absolutely yeah
this is like way entertaining it doesn't
pull you into it like a good immersive
story does but it pulls you into it just
by what the [ __ ] are they going to try
to pull on me next
then what's he going to do next
it's just because it's nothing but
action movie
big but
big budget arnold schwarzenegger style
action movie tropes over and over and
over again did the whole thing [ __ ]
blade runner tropes [ __ ] shout outs
to blade runner shout outs the [ __ ]
predator
to alien to robocop
to um just everything every it's ripping
off every [ __ ] thing and it knows you
know that it knows that you saw those
movies even the lines i shot at it and
it disappeared that's [ __ ] predator
predator one those eyes they disappeared
you know it was looking mac when he saw
the predator and you don't see that you
don't see the the monster really
until the end until the very end and and
which is weird because i think a lot of
the posters at the time had the monster
on it so you kind of knew what it looked
like and it looked good i thought it
does look it does look like the venom
symbiote it doesn't do much at the very
end though it doesn't it's not like a
big long sequence and it sets it up just
like an 80 just like an 80s movie it
sets it up for a sequel you know that
maybe it's not dead you know but yeah or
maybe there's another one or something
like that yeah because there's like one
after they kill it
uh you know there's bubbles like but
there there isn't a long fight sequence
where you kill it and then it turns out
it's not it's not dead and then you
gotta kill it again that was very 80s
you had to kill it three or four times
maybe they ran out of money i guess they
ran out of money and they didn't they
kill it once
which and then it's like oh baby
but that's
they really they really kind of messed
up because well like i said at that
point the main director had left because
of the stress
and they brought in another guy and they
were probably just trying to finish the
[ __ ] thing yeah probably just get it
over with and i mean and the movie the
finish movie isn't all that long i think
it was 93 minutes there are a couple of
scenes that were taken out uh which i
saw i think they're on youtube like i
saw them and
no not really um basically they're the
one scene is just kind of like because
you know how dick durkin like there's a
running gag about how he gets laid every
night yeah um there's one scene where
him and harley stone go to his apartment
and you get to meet his wife or
girlfriend or whatever but that didn't
really like i mean it was funny but it
wasn't really like anything to do
danny's going off about too many of
these modern movies has homages well
that's the joke man because this is not
a modern movie it was a movie of those
days
yeah it is uh homaging [ __ ] like i said
like i said when we started this video
it's homage [ __ ] back in the day when it
was too early to homage but they would
[ __ ] you they
we don't care if this movie only came
out a couple years ago two years ago
already but that was part of the joke if
you asked me i mean
i would i would have laughed my ass off
dead
like i mean it kind of works like i said
this movie
it is just it's never boring
no no and i think like like i said my
favorite thing and everybody's
well everybody like not kim catrol i
guess but like everybody else is kind of
like overacting but not in a way that's
like obnoxious they're a little bit over
acting but but in a fun way well you
like like in total recall
the tone is total recall it definitely
is that's like a yeah that's a good call
because i'm just kind of like because i
mean the whole thing the whole hilarious
thing about rucker howard's character
and he's just acting crazy and paranoid
and then like he does [ __ ] like you know
he's just totally spiked up on caffeine
all the time and he's like taking
people's pens and stirring his coffee
like a [ __ ] like that and then he gets
like called into the into the superior's
office like what the [ __ ] are you doing
you know what i mean so it's very much
action movie cliches yeah um but then
there's like so it's kind of like
you know like beverly hills cop or
something like that but then there's
like a whole bunch of like horror
elements like this this is pretty gory
yeah it was this is this would have been
r-rated
yeah which there's there wasn't any well
besides conan there wasn't any r-rated
arnold schwarzenegger yeah i mean this
had to be our radio oh yeah because
there's there's lots of tits in it and
it's ass and it's very gory it's very
bloody yeah and it's not real convincing
glory but it's just like okay do it yeah
it's like whole rooms full of blood and
like somebody lay in there with like
their heart ripped out and their ribs
like sticking out yeah so yeah it is
very good yeah i liked it
yeah i thought you might yeah because i
remembered i saw it i don't remember the
first time i saw it because i feel like
the weird thing that happened with this
movie
this was 1992
it came out
and
it seemed like when it first came out
like it got a lot of good like word of
mouth and like it had a really good like
advertising campaign around it like the
trailers and people were like oh that
looks good
but then like it sort of tanked like a
lot of critics didn't really like it
they just thought it was sort of dumb
and derivative it was too soon
but well yeah but the other thing too is
that it came out like pretty much the
same time as the la riots were going on
oh yeah so i kind of feel like that
[ __ ] it up some yeah so this is
definitely one of those movies that
didn't really get much i mean it didn't
make its money back is even though it
only cost like seven million to make i
think it only it made less than six
million back like at the box office but
this is definitely one of those ones
that when it came out on vhs
like words started to get around and
actually for a time i heard that um i
was watching oliver harper's thing about
it and he said that in the uk
uh this was actually like the top rental
for a significant period of time oh i'd
watch this drunken heartbeat
oh yeah like this is
wildly wildly entertaining yeah i just
you know and i had forgotten like how
good it was i wouldn't mind having this
as a as a blu-ray in my collection yeah
yeah yeah it'd be this would be a good
one i mean when i was watching it last
night i was just like laughing my ass
off i'm like this is [ __ ] great yeah
i haven't forgotten how [ __ ] fun this
movie is it's not on par with
velocipaster
because velocipaster the the tone is
well that's that's the platonic ideal
yeah but it's of the good bad movie yeah
and velocipaster is homage and [ __ ] from
uh third remember 30 years ago 40 years
ago their homage and [ __ ] remember three
years ago remember two years ago [ __ ]
it's just kind of funny to me you know
i liked it i appreciated it
because i kind of pictured a bunch of
down british people on the crew [ __ ]
kind of poking fun how ridiculous that
genre is which it is it was ridiculous
back then yeah it was self-deprecating
back then maybe that's what it i kind of
feel like because i feel like a lot of
the humor in this is maybe more british
humor than american yeah uh so maybe
that's why
the british make it make laughing at the
american sense of humor but not in a
real overt way yeah like it's very
because it's very kind of like i don't
want to say it's necessarily dry but it
is like a little more sarcastic yeah i
guess yeah yeah but americans will love
this you got to put that in there oh the
americans will love this put that in
there those [ __ ] idiots
you just see it you know but it is very
funny like i i think it's very funny and
like i said i laughed out loud but like
i said it's not a comedy yeah not really
i would call it really it is it was
meant to be entertaining
it was meant to have humor in it yeah
but it was not
they were taking it seriously they
weren't trying to go outside the scope
of the
they're not trying to go outside the
scope of the genre they were doing
things that other that that would that
other other movies do inside the genre
and still stay inside of it
you know what i mean uh yeah because if
you go too far out you're now parroting
it it's now a pretty like airplane
that's not what it was yeah it's
definitely not a parody yeah no but then
it's not a completely serious it's you
know it's
it's got comedy in it but it's not a
comedy i would call it like an action
horror
with a little bit of sci-fi yeah action
uh
sci-fi action horror
with comedy yeah but not but it's not a
comedy it's it's not really comedy in
the way you would think it's more kind
of like um
well the comedy is like it's like
situational
it more comes from
the it more comes from like the dialogue
between the characters like being kind
of funny and just like the situations
being kind of like absurd yeah it's
absurdity yeah in the way that
so it's not so much comedy it's more
like absurdity yeah but it's absurd in
the in the way that total recall is
absurd yes in the way that a running man
is absurd okay yeah
uh
it knows it's it knows it's being absurd
you're supposed to [ __ ] go with it
you know yeah both all those movies were
like that
they're like you think that's bad look
at it what about this it's like
something out of idiocracy
the movie it is idiocracy it's kind of
like that yeah well no i'm saying that's
a movie that they would watch yeah in
the idiocracy universe
[Laughter]
just funny you know yeah it's just i but
like i said i had seen it a while back
and i just had a feeling i was like and
i kept seeing it like on amazon because
it's on free on amazon prime
and i was just kind of like man i i
should get time to watch that because i
feel like he'd really really like that
and i kind of wanted to see it again too
so last night i started to watch it and
then it's like i was like man i forgot
how [ __ ] yeah okay how [ __ ] great
this baby what i'm gonna give it praise
for is that it's not a lazy movie
okay they thought about it
they wrote about [ __ ] they knew [ __ ] was
ridiculous and they kind of underlined
certain things
but they
so it
it was not a lazy movie
um
they just were working with what they
had
they actually kind of they kind of
delivered a lot more it was that movie's
punching pretty above its budget you
know um because they made little
they made little custom
[ __ ]
things to show you uh
they did absurd [ __ ] like he's like he
lit his [ __ ]
cigar with a blowtorch that he'd pull up
a damn military vehicle without even
seeing anything
and then he moved on that was just the
thing grabbing his boss and forgrab you
know guys fighting inside the damn
station house over [ __ ]
[ __ ] looking at each other too long
like they were going to kill one another
just it's it's hammy but it's supposed
to be
yeah
and the more i think about it like the
more the more that i like it let's watch
it the only like i said the only
complaint and this isn't even really a
complaint because i know how troubled
the production was is that
some of this stuff isn't like the
monster like the reason for the monster
like it's not really explained like is
it a demon is it satan
and they even go into like because it
leaves like the
thing like on your ceiling and they
never really explained it but that's
okay like i said it's it doesn't matter
that happened in a lot of d movies yeah
that's what i mean they just kind of
like forgot about it so i'm just like
[ __ ] it whatever like don't think about
it don't think about it too hard it's
that was cool wasn't it okay next thing
yeah that's that's yeah that's all
they're doing that's what i that's kind
of like because i i know that it was
like cobbled together from a couple
different ideas yeah it's probably why i
said there's probably like a lot of
ideas that they had that they didn't
really develop fully but like i said as
i i don't care i'll forgive pretty much
anything as long as the movie entertains
me and this one absolutely they knew it
was absurd yeah they knew it was absurd
they just got they're gonna love it yeah
just keep going
so i can definitely see why like when
this came out on vhs like why it started
getting like a cult following yeah
because yeah this is absolutely the kind
of movie that would have a cult
following yeah now it makes you want to
see uh death machine
yeah death machine i want to see that
maybe we can watch it we'll probably
well not tonight because we got to do a
haunting today but tomorrow
danny rowling said what's tomorrow's a
haunting episode review so i can watch
it we had a request uh somebody said we
to do uh where evil lurks
and i don't think we've done that one
before so we'll probably do that one i
think that's season four i'll find it
if i'm not mistaken like i can look it
up because it was 2007 and i think that
was uh season four so it'll probably be
where evil lurks unless we watch it and
then like see another one like another
one better but it'll probably be that
one
so cooking is definitely all right so uh
yeah thanks for hanging out with us
today uh have a good rest of your
weekend remember tomorrow we're gonna be
doing a haunting mondays that's
something we do every week now we're
gonna be talking about a haunting
episode uh so that should be fun so be
sure to be here for that and we will see
you guys again tomorrow
bye